Таких не було, як ця.
Ця оборонна синагога — окремий тип.
До того ж вона одна із найвідоміших на Волині,
її визначили світовою пам'яткою сакрального мистецтва.
Втратити таку сакральну споруду
і забути про євреїв Острога
в межах історії України — це втратити назавжди пазл:
до кінця картинку не скласти.
І це, я думаю, була така матеріальна спадщина,
яка говорить, що це було.
Крім наративів, книжок, літератури, артефактів.
От, синагога велика, ще й XVI століття.
Я народився в єврейській родині.
Вона була доволі таки асимільована:
мама моя з Могилів-Подільського, мало знає про іудаїзм.
А батько пам'ятав, як він був з батьком
в синагозі, з моїм дідом.
Довгий шлях був до визнання, що це мій крок.
Роз'їзджав по цвинтарях єврейських
України, Польщі, Угорщини,
дивився сакральні місця і зрозумів,
що ця споруда може бути втрачена,
і разом з нею буде втрачено пам'ять про ту громаду,
котра тут, в Острозі, існувала.
Я відкопав 16 синагог в Острозі.
З них із того, що збереглося, це оця велика синагога,
найстаріша, тобто побудована десь у XVI столітті,
і перебудовувалася вона за кошти Семуеля Едельса:
він добудував жіночу двохрівневу галерею,
вікна з'явилися збоку,
західний фасад і змінив покрівлю.
І ті, що ви бачите отвори на атіках,
ми їх відтворили, як і було тоді.
Це був символ того, що вона була оборонна.
Це такий східний фортпост міста Острога,
і вона входила в систему оборонних споруд.
І до 1930-го року в 16 синагог заходить радянська влада
просто 17-го вересня, бо кордон тут поряд,
і на цьому релігійне життя євреїв закінчилося,
як і багатьох етносів, які тут проживали.
Тут був склад, хоча були наміри зробити з неї і хлібозавод.
Я знайшов в архіві документи:
в хлібозавод мали перетворити, де був склад.
Отут було місця найсвятіше, ніби Арон Койдеш,
там де алтарі в східній частині храму.
Тут зберігалися Тори, тут було все вивалено,
і сюди завантажували продукти.
І було зроблено ще два поверхи,
там отвори ще лишилися на стінах де-не-де,
і місторг використовував його як склад.
У той момент, коли я сюди привіз цеглу,
з'являється хлопчина і приносить мені ключ —
червоний ключ з Маген Давіда, з гіркою,
ну такий чугунний чи залізний, я думаю століття XIX.
Ну нічого особливого, звичайний ключ.
І я згадую легенду, а може, і не легенду.
В 1939-му році загубили ключ від синагоги.
І це, як розказував ребе, погана прикмета,
і нашу громаду чекають катаклізми.
Ну, 1939-й рік, зрозуміло, що радянська влада
зайшла і закінчилося релігійне життя.
В 1941-му році прийшли нацисти –
закінчилось взагалі життя.
І тут ключ з'являється,
той, який сповіщав про негаразди.
І це такий символ, тож я думаю,
що все буде добре, із синагогою буде все добре.
Досвід у будівництві і реставрації маю,
бо я інженер-будівельник і займався реставрацією.
Але до синагоги руки не доходили.
Остання така крапля була в тому, що я це маю зробити,
я останній, хто тут лишився і у стані це зробити,
— це була стаття Сергія Кравцова
в журналі «Європейська та єврейська спадщина».
І він написав статтю «Пам'ятати, що забути».
Така там можливо була і іронія,
і сарказм, адресовані владі,
а я в той момент в міській раді багато років
будівельником був, котрий міг це зробити.
З європейською, американською, ізраїльською діаспорами
які тут приїзжають в Острог, бувають тут,
і розуміють, що це їхня спадщина,
Діалог із ними був, але значить не до кінця був,
не переконав, не пояснив, не розказав.
Я думав, що був причетний, був у тому ланцюгу
між сакральним і діями, між теорією і діями.
Я вирішив, що маю достатньо навичок і можливостей,
техніку свою маю, риштування свої, персонал свій.
І я вирішив, зателефонувавши одному приятелю,
з яким ми тут кілька кладовищ рятували в Україні,
він французьський підданий, Меіргоба Ізраель,
і він мені повірив.
Він мені приніс 1000 $, я мав 5000 $ своїх, і ми стартували.
А потім якось так пішла робота,
пішли заліпки, фірма працювала.
Усе, що було у мене збережено,
я все витратив на синагогу.
Ще багато хто тут долучався:
однокласники з Канади, ще хтось там з Рівного.
100, 200, 300$, невеликі суми.
А тут витрачено десь близько 180 000 $.
Почали з того, що ми зліз спиляли з покрівлі,
і з того, що зафіксували стіни.
Зсередини тут провалля було.
Зварили металевий каркас, закинули кранами двома,
на щастя, крани свої, і зробили покрівлю.
Це був такий перший крок, і потім пішло якось:
і фронтони, потім залатали отвори, вчіпились в фасади,
поштукатурили, вікна – була мрія,
і знайшлись гроші і на вікна.
Звідси вивезли 28 тон сміття — зсередини і зовні.
Це ми все вручну, до того ж з допомогою
громади баптистів Острога.
Вона з радістю допомогли,
за дуже малі гроші все це вигребли нагору.
Бувають моменти, що «я зможу чи не зможу»,
але після того, як вже з'явилася покрівля,
я вважаю, що щоб там не сталося, вона буде жива,
і якщо навіть не я, то хтось після мене зможе її зберегти.
Бо якби я не втрутився, покриття би впало,
далі потягнуло би колони, і тут лишилися б руїни.
Ідея моя — відтворити двохярусну жіночу галерею
і західний фасад, і там зробити виставку музейну,
бо багато експонатів збираємо ми, зокрема і я маю багато їх,
і багато експонатів є в нашому заповіднику.
І ці приміщення передати в Острозький заповідник,
щоб там була постійна єврейська виставка.
Якщо це не показати, то знову не буде
цієї зустрічі українсько-єврейської.
Говорити, що ту історію творили євреї разом
з поляками і українцями не завжди негативно.
Тобто є такий шанс показати, що не все втрачено,
що можна зберегти і історію,
і традиції, і стосунки — це основне.
І наступного, 2019-го року, буде 80 років, як вона була закрита.
То оце своєрідний дедлайн, щоб сюди внести Тору,
і тут почалось активне релігійне життя.
Я вважаю, що це такий шанс зберегти
хоч що-небудь із того, що було, і найбільше —
це Велика синагога Семуеля Едельса.
Ну я сподіваюсь, що з Божою допомогою все буде.
Не може бути все легко.
Буде тяжко, а якщо тяжко,
то ти на правильному шляху.